[Música]
y los animales indios
dios dios
dios es tan bueno
[Música]
yo
los ciclos sagrados
y
[Música]
porque por naturaleza dios es un dios
porque dios es todo a variantes
omnisapiente son interesantes sabe todo
esto
[Música]
eso es muy aburrido es perfectamente lo
que sucede en todas partes
[Música]
es perfecto
de estos
vigencia
el problema es el momento en el que un
muchachito y este muchachito se llama
pico della mirandola es uno de los
jovencitos que a los 22 años
se aventó a tratar de responder
seguramente lo hubieran invitado a este
foro a decir el señor pico cuando hacer
su tema y su tema es qué demonios es el
hombre y entonces empezó a juntar a
todos los intelectuales de la época y
nadie le en su caso sin embargo él entró
en una connotación muy interesante de lo
que va a ser el hombre dice pico della
mirandola el hombre puede hacer lo que
ni los animales ni dios pueden hacer
tal vez
cuando digo pecado estoy hablando del
concepto y brice libres no tiene la
connotación de pecado a la que estamos
acostumbrados en las tradiciones judías
cristianas sino más bien el inglés
quiere decir ir en contra de él y
generar una estructura que vaya en
contra de un clímax o de una estructura
perfectamente establecida luego entonces
los seres humanos podemos tener que
podemos tener historia podemos tener
educación porque tenemos esta capacidad
de cuestionarnos la pregunta y hacernos
preguntas forma parte de esa naturaleza
intrínseca que nos diferencia
estrictamente de los seres divinos y de
los animales por eso nos guste o no
estamos destinados a ser filósofos y
saben por qué porque dios no tiene
preguntas
los animales tampoco tienen preguntas
ellos solamente tienen respuestas el
único ser vivo sobre la tierra que tiene
preguntas que pueden hacerse esta
capacidad de hacerse preguntas es el
hombre y esto es muy interesante porque
porque a partir de eso nosotros podemos
empezar a generar dice es federico
nietzsche los hombres no tienen o no
existe la auto logía es decir no existe
siempre existe la genealogía es decir
esta capacidad que tenemos de ir creando
y con que creas creas con las preguntas
prepara hacen preguntas dicen por ahí
esto es bastante complicado realmente
hay que tener una capacidad de acceder y
de empezar a morir segundo a segundo
cuando digo morir segundo a segundo
quiere decir que lo que en un momento
fue en ese mismo segundo va a empezar a
morir lo que en este momento vuelve a
nacer
en ese momento vuelve empezaron a hacer
otra cosa
y entramos en un concepto de una serie
del morir a perpetuidad y entonces
pensando en ello dije que es lo que nos
puede representar de alguna manera un
lenguaje con el ser divino o con la
totalidad y esto es la música porque la
música de alguna manera federico
nietzsche era pianista y también autor
de algunas obras en decía en el momento
en el que yo me alejo de la música me
estoy alejando de la naturaleza
intrínseca de todo lo que puede ser
conste que no dije de todo lo que es
sino de todo lo que puede ser porque la
música porque la música es la
combinación de sonidos y silencios yo la
música no la puedo conseguir únicamente
con sonidos para que esta música tiene
que existir también el silencio y
entonces la música nos conecta
precisamente con lo que es y lo que y
con lo que no es esta parte absurda que
nuestra mente racional muchas veces nos
obstaculiza en este momento nos
posiciona en un concepto todo abarcante
de lo que realmente existe y hablando de
música ustedes podrán preguntarse
que realmente puede significar desde el
punto de vista más literal este origen y
este nacer existe una canción una
canción que me gusta mucho es una
canción japonesa que se llama sakura
sakura
[Música]
sakura sakura no es otra cosa más que la
descripción de la flor de cerezo la flor
del silencio tiene una connotación muy
interesante en japón primero es una flor
sumamente frágil casi no vive en el
momento en el cristal es tomaron esa
cura y les toca en este momento muere y
de alguna manera está representada la
flor de sakura con el alma del samurai y
el alma del samurai dice la única forma
que tú puedes venir lo único que
justifica la vida es la el eterno y
constante contacto perpetuamente con la
muerte y lo que estamos hablando aquí es
precisamente de un himno hacia todo
afectos va a que ellos su invitación a
todo aquello que va a perecer porque a
eso venimos venimos a morir segundo a
segundo cada momento cada cosa que damos
por hecho en ese momento habrá que
cuestionar y ahí es en donde entra la
filosofía porque en el momento en el que
yo digo me puedo acercar y puedo tener
esta realidad la puedo agarrar con mis
manos en ese momento existe dentro de mí
ese eje
interno que me dice puede ser pero puede
también no se puede ser de alguna u otra
manera pero yo no lo he visto yo
prefiero mejor quedarme
en algo que yo conozco yo puedo quedarme
en la vida de los conceptos conceptos
viene del latín ya tus
y agarrar nosotros como seres humanos
pensamos que podemos obtener la realidad
que podemos agarrar la realidad y como
como pensamos eso entonces nos amarramos
a conceptos y eso se les llama idea
lejos el ideal que ustedes quieran
el ideal por familia verdad o relación
de hombre de mujer de naturaleza
todos esos son conceptos pero a través
de la filosofía y específicamente a
través del enfoque de federico nietzsche
él nos invita a cuestionar porque es
imposible no cuestionar no existe la
posibilidad de que yo pueda estar ahí
sentado es cierto de que existe una
verdad absoluta perenne y estática sino
que siempre existe la posibilidad de que
ésta sea de otra manera y esto es
precisamente el tema de la inocencia
federico nietzsche nos habla de tres
animales o de tres enfoques diferentes
para poder crear la realidad el primero
de ellos es el camello el que me dio es
alguien que va cargando tiene una
historia no es capaz de decirle no a su
pasado
el león que es aquel que va a enfrentar
y va a tratar de hacer una nueva
posibilidad pero existe el último es al
que yo les invito a poder encarnar los y
ahí viene mi amor por los niños y es que
los niños son la mejor escuela que hay
porque los niños tienen un arma fabulosa
un arma maravillosa y esta arma se llama
inocencia federico ricci lo menciona y
dice la inocencia del devenir esto qué
quiere decir quiere decir que yo tengo
un pasado y que está ahí estuvo pero que
yo lo voy a olvidar porque no me
interesa y entonces vienen los niños se
revisan a mí no necesariamente me
interesa la maestría es decir la
competencia que todo destruye más bien
me interesa
darle la espalda a la maestría para
enfrentar el misterio para la inocencia
de prevenir y si todas bien en el pasado
vivimos anhelando lo vivimos recordando
lo queremos recuperar ese pasado que
también que también los datos o también
los pudo retratar lo mal que queremos
olvidarlo y entonces en ese momento
generamos un canto en el pasado si vamos
al futuro tenemos la esperanza por eso
federico nietzsche era también un cerdo
contrincante de la esperanza porque
porque es algo que aún no existe y él
decía vamos a estar en un eterno retorno
en una inocencia del devenir que lo
único que me va a permitir es estar
generando escollos a partir de la
posibilidad de ir descubriendo mundos
nuevos segundo a segundo existen dos
tipos de fuerzas fuerzas activas y
fuerzas reactivas cuáles son las fuerzas
activas las matemáticas la física
son aquellas con las cuales se les llama
también fuerzas democráticas porque son
iguales para todas partes es decir estas
fuerzas son igual para ricos son igual
para pobres son iguales en china y
también son en cualquier parte del mundo
las matemáticas son siempre las mismas
y para que puedan existir se requiere un
debate yo tengo que convencerme
yo tengo que dialogar contigo para que
esos principios puedan existir ese es el
producto de las fuerzas reactivas
cualquier fuerza cualquier tema del que
tú estés dispuesto a debatir ya
enfrentar o a contravenir es una fuerza
reactiva por otro lado está la fuerza
activa dice federico nietzsche y esta
fuerza activa es maravillosa porque es
una fuerza aristocrática desde el punto
de vista filosófico porque es algo que
está ahí pero que no le interesa ser
debatido ni cuestionado por nadie de qué
estoy hablando de la más muy grande
religión prestada o engendrada por el
creador el arte en el arte al arte no le
interesa convencer a nadie
el artista anuncia y denuncia el artista
enfrenta el artista confronta el artista
no tiene el más mínimo interés de quedar
bien con nadie al artista lo que le
interesa es posicionar una idea
independientemente si es aceptada o no
esa es una de las razones por la cual
por las cuales la mayor cantidad de los
artistas han sido siempre relegados y
muchos de ellos ni siquiera han tenido
la capacidad o la posibilidad de ver los
resultados de su propuesta por eso ellos
entran entran en esta posibilidad que
existe de ser alguien independientemente
de lo que su comunidad les manda a pedir
y lo más interesante es que en el
artista encontramos también un
representante férreo y este
representante es el niño porque el niño
no le interesa quedar bien con nadie y
sabe por qué porque sabe que no es nadie
es más no le interesa hacer nadie a él
lo que le interesa es empezar a
cuestionarse minuto a minuto para que no
existen momentos mejores que otros
simplemente existen
potencialidades existen posibilidades es
el mundo de la posibilidad que no el
mundo de la realidad para él no existe
las cosas hechas para él no existen los
patrones formados para él existen
siempre posibilidades alguna forma en la
que ésta pueda hacer mejor en la que la
vida pueda ser mejor
pero tenemos bien todos los que estamos
aquí la mayor cantidad principalmente
los adultos por los niños no puedo
hablar todos tenemos piano tenemos miedo
a preguntarnos por qué es posible que
encontremos nuevas respuestas y nosotros
somos temerosos a esas nuevas respuestas
porque ello implica mucha
responsabilidad que es la
responsabilidad de enfrentar a un status
quo académico a un estado oscuro
religioso a un status quo político a un
status quo familiar etcétera a los niños
no les interesa esto por eso viven en el
mundo de la pregunta dicen que cualquier
imbécil pueda dar respuestas pero
solamente los muy doctos son capaces de
generar preguntas y generamos preguntas
porque no tenemos miedo no tenemos miedo
a la filosofía porque la filosofía es
eso filosofía es cuestionar filosofía es
arrojarse a un abismo entender la
capacidad de estar en una montaña y
estar estar haciendo esto los niños se
arrojan una y otra vez y saben qué pasa
no pasa nada nosotros estamos en un
abismo y queremos preguntar pero no nos
atrevemos a hacerlo
que corremos el riesgo de encontrar
respuestas yo prefiero mejor irme a un
pasado que me construyó un pasado que me
dio seguridad un pasado que me hizo ser
lo que soy y que con ello vivo tranquilo
si es que podemos llamarle a eso vida
porque dicen por ahí que nosotros la
mayor cantidad de los adultos realmente
mueren sin haber vivido inicialmente han
vivido fueron los niños porque porque no
están frente a esta posibilidad y yo les
puedo decir simplemente
que cuando estamos cuando estamos en
este mismo siempre tenemos la
incertidumbre de saltar y de ver qué
madera algo que voy a caer y que me voy
a golpear el filósofo y el niño se
arrojan a este abismo y saben una cosa
la red aparecerá no no no la red no el
filósofo sabe y el niño también que en
el momento en el que se arroja
ninguna red va a aparecer
cuando ustedes se arrojan de corazón se
darán cuenta que el piso no existe
[Aplausos]